cette commission denquête da aucun
pouvoir
mais aucun à l'égard du chef de l'état
aucun nous faisons notre travail et il
n'y a pas de politique dans notre
travail
voyez-vous philippe bas muriel jourda et
moi même nous appartenons à des
formations politiques différentes mais
nous avons décidé d'être unie cohérent
pourquoi pas ce que nous recherchons la
vérité quels sont les dysfonctionnements
qui ont eu lieu au coeur de l'état à
tous les niveaux et comment y remédier
nous n'allons pas délivrer des sanctions
non nous cherchons la vérité et nous
cherchons à ce que l'état la république
et les pouvoirs publics fonctionnent au
mieux
c'est notre mission qui nous est dévolue
par la constitution mais nous n'avons
aucunement l'intention de porter
atteinte à qui que ce soit et pour ce
qui est de l'exploitation politique je
me vous dire que c'est la commission
denquête de l'assemblée nationale qui a
explosé en vol
parce qu'il y avait un conflit politique
en son sein tandis que nous on a des
débats politiques dans l'hémicycle qui
juste à côté c'est bien normal mais pour
une commission denquête nous sommes tous
unis pour trouver la vérité
trouvez les dysfonctionnements y porter
réponse